[Music]
hello guys and welcome to a new video
today we have a Honda Civic 2006 uh all
keys lost we're going to make a new key
and I will show you step by step how to
how to program the key how to generate
the key
and I'm going to use the um the out IM
im608 and I'll use the KD key as well
and I will use a software from from the
kitty so first of all you have to plug
the uh OBD which is um on the on the
left side right
here
okay let's generate the key right now so
the software for this one it's the Honda
Civic Thailand
we generate quick the the
key uh it's a wireless key because it's
a chip on
board okay
perfect Let's test the remote
freny perfect make sure it's a 433
fragen for the Europe cars only for the
Korean cars I think uh they have three
frency okay so let's put the ignition
on perfect we have the ignition on as
you see the um immobilizer is blinking
the key the Green Key
uh let's go on
emo let's go on accept then it's a Honda
perfect make sure you have enough
voltage into the battery to be like
about
1160 I think is the minimum if you don't
have this voltage just plug uh uh the
jump leads or a booster on the on a
battery let's try on automatic selection
let's see if we can read the
VIN
uh
okay uh it's a blade
key on the
Civic okay that's the V number
perfect let's press
yes
um let's go on the control unit I'll go
manually uh immobilizer
Honda OBD 3pin
okay uh ignition is
on let's press okay again
this the fourth blade Key System perfect
make sure you stop everything before you
start the process make sure it's uh the
a air condition it's off uh the radio
and everything like that you can save
much more battery as you see the um the
vent has been uh has been uh on I I just
turned it off and uh it increased the
voltage into the into the
battery uh I'll press all keys lost
let's see how many keys in the
system two keys were registered okay
perfect uh we will press all keys lost
like that it will delete the old keys
and um the old key is not going to be
functional and it's going to be only
this key functional old Keys
lost and the number of keys so we have
only one
key
okay perfect enter number of keys
one so we need to turn off the ignition
now uh let's turn on the ignition
again just follow the out instructions
open time out okay so we have an error
here but let's try to started
again turn the ignition on with the
registered key we don't have a
registered key what's this error okay
let's try one more time all key lost
number of keys
one okay so turn the ignition off
ignition
on okay
perfect ignition off ignition on using
the same
key imobilizer is still
blinking it's saying Turn ignition off
ignition on with the same
key if the mobilizer is still blinking
that means we haven't generated the the
right key so we need to choose another
one he ask me if the mobilizer goes out
so it's not out no current Keys too okay
I'll try one more time with this key
let's see if it's working if don't I
will try to generate a new one
okay try to take off the
ignition ignition
on okay ignition off ignition
on ignition off ignition on again
yeah so the immobilizer is still
blinking let's try to
generate a new
key so that's the
remote vehicle remote and go to Honda
Honda okay let's
see let's try see this one says Civic
okay we can also look on the feedbacks
here Civic 2012 Honda Civic 2008 we have
a 2006 one add didn't K star okay so
let's try
this let's see if it's working generate
uh
Wireless okay perfect ignition on
okay all keys lost
again
okay turn ignition off ignition on again
ignition off again ignition
on so yes the mobilizer it's turned off
right now
uh yes turn ignition
off ignition on
again current key only one restra key
turn ignition
off cycle the key let's see if the
engine will
start there perfect guys okay we have
one more thing to check see if the
remote is
working it's perfectly
working let's try to close the
[Music]
door yeah
perfect all done let's check one more
time the key to see if he starting the
engine clutch start stop
button and yes well done thank you so
much guys for watching my video if you
like the video don't forget to share and
subscribe and if you have any questions
you can leave me a comment I'll try to
answer as quick as I can have a nice day